hello this is Sal Khan i'm the founder  of the khan academy so the way that the  system works right now is you get  promoted grade to grade even if you  didn't fully master the concepts maybe  should be the other way around what do  you think are the pros and cons of a  competency-based system what do you have  to do to actually go further to  personalize a classroom to allow every  student to work at their own pace if you  want to participate we are going to  launch a conversation on google+ we're  going to pick out some of the folks who  have some of the most insightful  comments and they're going to join me on  october first on a hangout on air  you